I'm extremely low on B12, and I am anemic still, but improved slowly, so I should not be taking
a B12 methyl comolomy, but instead hydroxyl comolomy. Yes, that's my opinion, you should be
taking hydroxyl comolomy, methyl comolomy. The only people I think that have cancer that should be
taking methyl comolomy is if you also have high homocysteine. So if you have elevated homocysteine
levels, then you need to take methyl comolomy. This is actually, I could be methyl comolomy
and could be methyl folane too, but my homocysteine levels are normal. Okay, so then go on a hydroxyl
comolomy, or the adenosyl comolomy, either one. You might have that in your, in your, you know,
covered, but either one of those. We should also use a loss edge because B12 is difficult to
absorb for a lot of people through the gut lining, and a person can be taking plenty of B12 in whatever
form, but they have a peritious in evening. I mean, they don't make the enzyme for the pathway
to absorb it through the gut wall. So that's why you take a loss edge and you
refrain from sucking at it too quickly, because you wanted to absorb through the buckle,
Mucosa, of the cheeks, not through swallowing, you know, just sucking at the loss edge and swallowing
the deliciousness of the tasty loss edge, because you wanted to absorb in your mouth, but not
in the gut. So be careful of that. Anybody that's taking B12.